I want to steal man the postmoderns
right and then talk about what what the
competition really is here okay
the postmoderns have in my opinion one
point and it's a good one but it's one
point it's not the basis for field after
field the one point is that we are
humans and we have only our perception
as the basis for everything we think and
even to the extent that you might have
tools that would allow you to see
something what we would claim is
objectively your interaction with those
tools is still subjective right so and
this is true it is true and it results
in a lot of places where bias leaks in
to what we believe even where it is
supposed to be absolutely analytical and
rigorous and devoid of all of the things
that might bias us it can't be totally
right now here's the problem with that
so that's the steel man version
perception is between you and the world
you can't escape that and because of
that bias is impossible to stamp out
completely and I believe that that's
actually that's accurate however if you
were going to try to stamp out bias the
number one tool you would want in your
arsenal arguably the only tool you need
is science because what science does the
entire reason that it exists the entire
reason that it has beaten every other
system is that it will tell you what's
true in spite of your bias now you have
to do it right if you have a corrupt
system if you have you know monetary
corruption that is influenced you know
how quote unquote science gets done
because it's only the people who succeed
at some sort of non-scientific
phenomenon like grant writing you have
repeat of a good old boy in networks are
just saying with peer-review yeah you
can have all kinds of things interfere
with proper science but if you can do
the science properly and you can be
vigilant about stamping out the things
that cause science not to be done
properly then science will force you to
discover the things that you don't
intuitively believe right that's what it
does and so yes the postmoderns are
right bias is a serious problem what do
you do about it yes I
to the extent that your science is
influenced by things that it shouldn't
be and is therefore baiance what's the
solution to that better science more
science it's science that's the answer
to post-modernism and it always has been
so so I'm gonna I'm gonna add I'm gonna
say okay I think if I have to pick one
it's gonna be science but I want two
things I mean I want more I want more
than that but I want science and I want
art because art allows you to view the
world to other people's lenses and you
know post-modernism at least it's modern
crazy corrupt instantiations are
specifically demanding of us that we not
see the world to other people's eyes
that if we claim to be able to than we
are somehow revealing our own bigotry
but art especially narrative art you
know as especially fiction in whatever
form but 2d art 3d art any of it
also just allows you to stand in someone
else's footsteps and see and science
does this in a very different way and
and if I have to pick one I pick science
but science and art together are are
going to be an incredibly potent
rejoinder to this movement and therefore
I am not too surprised to find the
shutdown stem movement and the the very
wide number of organizations that we are
hearing from and seeing in the arts that
are being gone after by this movement
it's it's they're being targeted so I
like this I still think it's the science
that narrowly corrects for the bias but
the fact is nobody reads scientific
papers
I mean scientists do write in their own
field and sometimes they read a little
farther afield than that but what moves
the world is the conclusions that you
come up with the counterintuitive things
that you discover through this process
that then get incorporated into
something beautiful and intuitive and
provocative enough to capture people's
attention which tends to be it's not
even always narrative I said I said it's
easier to point to a narrative but it's
not just out of 2d art 3d VR or you know
I was thinking about just staring it at
an amazing sculpture even an abstract
one it's it's
easier to do if it's if it's a non
abstract sculpture but yeah you learn
something about a different mind about a
different human beings mind by by
walking around some piece of art that's
been created that is the product of
another human mind and not even
necessarily mind the mind is an
interface and sometimes the mind is the
point and it's content is the point and
that's what you discover but even
something like you know there are some
of these images of sculptures that very
effectively capture the finest fabric
flowing as if in the wind and it's so
compelling yeah you know or there's a
famous sculpture with somebody's hand on
somebody's leg and the way the fingers
depress the skin of the person and the
point is it's so compelling that it
actually reveals something how could you
render something soft out of stone right
so even that counterpoint tells you
something about the way the world works
or I'm frequently stunned by what is
revealed by just simply changing one
parameter of something you can observe
yourself like stop motion reveal certain
things or you know the the way if you
look at clouds and mountains and the way
they interact in a time-lapse and the
thing is you can read in a textbook all
you want that the atmosphere functions
as a fluid right but until you see yeah
until you see what the mountain does to
the clouds as they move around it it's
it's it's like what we used to say you
know enzyme is a catalyst yes it's a
catalyst in the same way the factory is
a catalyst right a factory is a catalyst
for making cars right I mean you can so
having time lapse is obviously a fairly
modern phenomenon but I think also art
has has probably revealed what is
possible and opened up technological
worlds very often so the example that
came to mind when you were talking that
I imagine there's history written on
this and I just I don't know it but
pointillism the what is this 19th or
20th century 19 20th century turned the
century art form in which dots are used
to convey great precision in in vast
scenes seems to presage the idea of
pixels like you know this the the idea
that you can actually reveal things
through points was that in people's
heads in da Vinci's time well you might
have been she said you know so much was
but my art history is weak but yeah the
Impressionists predate point the formal
point listing so yeah and I think what
you're getting at is the retina is
actually it's the inverse of pixels it's
you know it's just as a camera sensor
would be yeah and there is this
interesting duality it's not the duality
of man but there is an interesting
duality between the continuous and the
discrete interpretation of the world and
there are certain things that are simply
discrete and there are other things that
are continuous and then there are many
things which do not fall wholly in one
or the other category
yeah and therefore one needs to spend
time borrowing from the alternative in
order to see what it is that you were
missing what's in your blind spot
because you had looked at it as discrete
when in fact it was continuous at some
level so and this is you know this is
science fiction serves this purpose as
well like scientific investigations have
gotten ideas from things that have been
written in science fiction in part
because what it what science fiction
reveals what art may reveal in other
forums is maybe the categories we are
currently using aren't right or maybe
the boundaries aren't quite where we
thought they were
or maybe the boundaries were where we
thought they were but those boundaries
are moving because other things are
changing and art can allow you to live
in that alternative of space for a
little bit and consider it and sometimes
like nope actually not right interesting
to spend some time there but that's not
right and sometimes it can cause people
to go ah actually I think I think we do
need an update or radical change we need
to we need to actually build a whole new
foundation over here with a new kind of
science because the categories we were
using you know of
I'm also not up to date on the various
older versions of what the world is made
of but you know it turns out that fire
earth water and air are not the the
basal elements of life right right so
it's sort of hints at the periodic table
but it didn't get there it's got the
wrong thing you don't get there and you
couldn't you could not just do a brick
in the wall model from fire earth water
and air to get to the periodic table you
actually need to go all the way back in
the decision tree to the question what
are what is it made of what are the
fundamentals and rebuild from there
[Music]